欢迎大家参加
FP101x 函数式程序设计
这门慕课
让我们现在就开始吧
在讨论其他事情之前 我想说的是
正如标题所说 这门慕课是关于函数式程序设计的
它不是一门 Haskell 课程 我们是将 Haskell
作为一门函数式语言 但我们不是学习如何用 Haskell 编程的
让我给你讲一个小故事吧
我经常旅行 开会
讲课 等等
旅行途中 我有很多时间来看电视
有一天晚上 当我随意调台时
看到一档求生类节目
里面一个人试着在晚上扎营
并且想要点火
但是火柴都湿了
也许他会很慌乱并说
我的火柴湿了 点不着火了
但他做的却是拿出一部手机
用他的刀
把电池从上面拆了下来 并打开了电池
之后电池开始燃烧
他就用这个点着了火
这也是我想在这门课中教给你的态度
当我们用 Haskell 学习函数式程序设计时
Haskell 是我们的火柴
在实际工作中 你可能没有火柴能用
但你仍然可以进行函数式编程 有时你需要拆开你的手机
打开你的电池才能生火 别认为这只是关于
Haskell 的 我们用是 Haskell 但教的是函数式程序设计
好了 现在让我们开始吧
我们要解决的是什么问题？
要解决的问题就是所谓的 软件危机
我们都知道开发者写代码十分困难
我们需要写大型的程序
同时又要缩减开发时间 降低开发成本
我们希望快速发布软件
又希望发布的软件正确无误
问题是我们如何写程序
来保证我们有信心认为软件正确工作呢？
我们又如何写代码
来实现快速发布
不是几年后才发布
而是几个月或者更短 一种现代编程语言中
常见的实现方式是 为编程语言增加特性
允许程序的表达方式简洁清晰 抽象层次也较高
我们在现代编程语言中使用的这些技术
都是基于函数式程序设计
基于 lambda 演算的概念
Haskell 是一种纯函数式编程语言
因此适用于这些概念的教学
函数式编程语言则提供一种十分优雅的框架
让我们在一个较高的抽象层次写代码
但正如我说过的 Haskell 只是一个工具
我们在这门课中所学到的东西
你可以用于任何编程语言 即使你用的是汇编语言
Java 或 PHP 或者 JavaScript 你在这里学习到的想法
可以立刻用在
无论你用的哪种编程语言中
那么什么是函数式编程语言呢？
可能的回答有很多
现在还没有明确的定义
如果我们考虑最纯的函数式编程语言
那么函数式编程语言就是使用数学函数编程的语言
这一定义适用于 Haskell 它本身是一门 纯函数式语言
在函数式语言中仅有很少几门是纯的
当然 我在说我们可以将这些技术应用到其他编程语言中 的时候
我们不能使用这个定义
我们要用的时下面的定义
函数式编程语言
是一种编程的风格
其中表达式比语句更为重要
我们想做的事情时用表达式组成程序
这些表达式都可以求值 因此我们可以把两个可以求值的表达式
组合起来成为一个更大的表达式
比较一下使用语句编程
当你将语句组合起来的时候 每条语句都有隐藏的副作用
这些副作用影响全局状态 它们通过全局状态实现通信
而使用表达式编程时
表达式返回一个值
我们直接将值组合起来 一门函数式编程语言
就是支持并且鼓励
使用表达式编程的语言
正如我说过的 大部分现代语言都支持这种风格
特别时通过支持 lambda 表达式来实现这一点
随着课程的进行 我们可以在很多语言中
看到函数式编程的例子
让我们从第一段代码开始吧
这是一种传统 Java 编程风格
我们要计算 1 到 10 的加和
我们做的方式 使用传统的过程式编程风格
它是基于语句的
我们做的第一件事是声明了一个整数类型的
变量 total 并将它初始化为 0
接下来我们用一个循环变量写一个 for 循环
你可以看到这边的变量 i
然后我们给 total 变量赋值
成为 total + i 你可以看到
这个程序是用一种
过程式的风格写的 我们有语句
我们有可变状态
我们过程式地执行一条语句接一条语句
更新状态来计算最终结果
这是你用 Haskell 编写相同程序的方法
你首先能看到的是
程序更加简洁 此外 没有语句了
只有两个表达式
右面这个 1 点点 10 （1..10）
创建了一个从 1 到 10 的整数列表
然后我们将这些整数相加
你可以看到我们将表达式
组合成为程序 一个表达式创建从 1 到 10 的列表
我们将它的返回值传给
sum 函数上 从而把内容求和
在 Java 8 中
你可以用 Java 8 的流（streams）
写同样的程序
我们将在未来的课程中深入探讨 Java 8
但现在我们只看用 Haskell 实现的方式
十分感谢
第二部分再见